[Music]
check mike
it's good miss mrs zoom has told me that
recording is in progress thus beginning
our interaction
with the machine here we go
don't you hate when podcasts start with
what they were talking about before the
podcast started eric well like i was
just saying to you before the podcast
yeah yeah i know i know what you mean
it's kind of like
isn't that our vibe though it's sort of
like hey we just sat down at the bar
with a beer come listen in
yeah you're coming in mid conversation
well i say that i hate when podcasts
start with what podcasts we're talking
about before the podcast started
but i'm sorry we have to do this eric
got me feeling kind of manifesto-y
because we were talking
earlier today
and what did you say something something
to the effect of
i like posthumanism it sounds pretty
good but when it comes down to it we're
not really arguing about anything that
matters
i don't know if i put it quite like that
but there's definitely like a limit to
my
interest in post-humanism i i
i think when it comes to like
post-humanism versus humanism or versus
transhumanism yeah okay i'll go with
post-humanism but i think when it
actually comes to anti-humanism i'm
maybe a little more on the side of the
anti-humanist
angle i guess you'd say with uh like d
starting with like nietzsche and running
through uh running through uh foucault
but
yeah
so we're if we're talking about
anti-humanism versus humanism
or i'm sorry anti-humanism versus
post-humanism
non-humanism could have be one of these
terms as well so you can have a
non-human
methodology
like i'd say
most of the sciences don't really care
if there's a human around or not if
you're if you're looking at a even if
it's a human brain if you're a
neuroscientist whether or not the human
exists is kind of outside the scope of
your of your method there and
non-humanism or anti-humanism says
something antagonistic towards you know
the humanist tradition well yeah i
i think um
if
anti-humanism
to me seems more like a methodological
choice it's not like misanthrope it's
not misanthropic it's not it's not a
hatred of humans or anything like that
it's it's a kind of methodological
decision
which
i believe people like lumen and systems
theorists make
as a point they make it themselves into
anti-humanists which is just to say that
when we're looking at systems
human
or individual is not the unit of
analysis here
well i would call post-humanism
something a little different the way
that it works uh in my mind is that it
takes the things
that were previously ascribed to you
know a human individual at the center of
all things and then gives that role to
something else so a system i would call
that post-humanism rather than
anti-humanism
because it's
taking the humanist aspects
and
diversifying them or de-centering them
rather than being against a human
yeah you could see a lot of this coming
out of derrida and deconstruction as
well it's it's not that we're making a
new center when you decenter the human
you're not putting something else in its
place you're more so making like a
plurality
right where
any anything cannot can occupy the
central position in but only temporarily
like you can't make it into a
foundationalism or you can't make it
into a kind of universalism
you just have to continuously de-center
continuously
self-critique what's whatever foucault
the senate like permanent critique kind
of approach
which
just
seems
like a journey that has no end i guess i
don't know maybe that's
maybe that's not satisfying for some
people but like i emphasize you know
post humanism is quite new and it
doesn't have a lot of its
terminology down there's different
interpretations
as we've been going through critical
cultural post-humanism technologically
focused animal focused it's all
kind of still very up in the air
all right well i'll challenge you on
saying
this comes down to arguing again about
things that nobody actually believes
i'll give a case maybe and you can uh
buy it or or challenge it because here's
where it matters to the listeners of
like of this podcast specifically
um because we do political theory a lot
of the time and we do
leftist fear risks a lot of the time
and this is actually where i where i
hang my hat because here's why it
matters um
the basis of our
politics
most of the options if you're if you're
shopping around in the marketplace of
ideas if you're shopping around you have
a few shelves to look at you got your
liberalisms
um you got your marxism or at least
nominal marxism you have your anarchism
or nominal anarchism
and each of these
and i wouldn't say marx himself by the
way i should attend that but if you're
shopping around all these politics
have at their center or the core
action that produces politics
is
usually self-interest
and that changes a little bit as
sometimes it is
class interest but most of the time if
you're libertarian or
liberal it really comes down to
individual self-interest is
the thing that makes politics
occur
and if if those self-interests are not
realized then you need an explanation
for that you need a descriptor that
deals with why people
didn't vote in their own self-interest
and that's where you have something like
ideology coming in and the explanation
there is if if they're not in there if
they're not acting in their interest
then they're under the sway of a magical
evil force called ideology or their
dupes
but if you take a post-humanist model of
politics meaning that you're not gonna
start with self-interest
people are not acting in their
self-interest they are reacting to the
systems that they are participating in
from day to day
without probably realizing it and
whether they realize it or not doesn't
really matter because these various
systems elicit responses and
self-interest never
in the end finally gets like reconvened
so to me post-humanist politics at least
the kind that we're talking about right
now
we might get to another version of
post-humanist politics which i think is
misnamed and stupid
but at least for me this is an
alternative explanatory framework as to
why the revolution hasn't happened yet
that doesn't need to make half of people
just too stupid
so i guess i should give examples
technology in the political process
media apparatuses
in the political process uh
where you're born what options you have
in terms of participation in systems or
becoming part of them all of this
matters much more in predicting
political outcomes
than just your beliefs
being at the center of it
yeah no i i remember what i said earlier
actually i i sometimes i felt like
sometimes i felt like post-humanist
arguments were unfolding against
positions that nobody really holds
i think i gave like
absolute universalism as an example
which it's not fair to say i guess some
people do think that way i guess but i i
feel like you know you stop the average
person on the street you say do you
think everything that that applies to
your world view should apply to
everybody else's world view they
probably say no
they probably
cite some kind of cultural relativism
and then they've fallen into my trap
because i could just say then oh
relativism is just the dualistic
opposition of
of absolutism
absolutism and relativism form a dualism
therefore you're a dualist so you must
be cart like some of those ways of
arguing
get me a little bit annoyed um
but yeah certainly i think the problem
with self-interest here as well is
when i go back to my big story
about
the
those we mentioned them earlier those
those those
were the great insults or the um
the sort of shocks to uh humans and our
our sort of central
position in our own worlds is it was you
know freud bringing up the unconscious
we're not really in control of that
and so sir bringing up language giving
us this idea of a kind of linguistic
preconditioning that leads to the sappor
sepia wharf hypothesis and marx saying
you know we don't really get to choose
what class we're born into
but
our interests tend to line up with those
classes like there's all these things
that aren't
against
humans being perfectly self-present and
under perfect self-control and the one
that we forget about in the humanities
quite often is darwin
and his idea of of evolution but what
comes out of that is this idea of the
survival of the fittest which is i
believe not darwin's term i think it was
herbert spencer or somebody like that
afterwards and you get social darwinism
but the the point is that you know every
creature is interested in its own
survival before everything else
and that kind of self-interest
right and that that doesn't get
challenged a lot until
well it doesn't get challenged quite so
much in the humanities
and this sort of
multi-species becoming seems to be more
the normal situation rather than
individuals of us pure individuals of a
species that are self-interested
interested in their own survival like
that story makes sense
and you can maybe apply it to
what population statistics and really
get some really great explanatory
stories out of it using even a
mathematically rigorous approach
but
what about what about interspecies
relationships what about
what about the fact that none of us are
really what we are
so how do we think about that and that
we don't have a great terminology to
understand
that the human is not really the human
it's always already
also
something else you are
you is to use the language of center you
are a center of all sorts of
interactions material and organic and
psychological and
social
and to call yourself an individual and
self-possessed and self-interested it
just seems to
you know
ignore all that which i see is
problematic
and i would never say that something
like just in case anyone's
misinterpreting i wouldn't say either of
us would ever claim that something like
self-interest
doesn't exist because obviously it does
it's a useful term it's not just a
mythical
magical illusion
but to say that that is the center of
politics
i think is just wrong and if you look
around it just looks wrong at least to
me because if everyone were acting in
their self-interest we wouldn't have the
type of world that
we have i would say
so a post-humanist mode of politics at
least my own personal brand of it goes
self-interest might be part of a process
but if you want to guess how something
is going to go
it's far better
far more predictive
to look at systems first so
what kind of media is present in a
political situation we talked about this
last week
what kind of media is present what kind
of technologies are present what
technologies have caught people
was i think the term we used so
basically you start with the environment
you don't start with individuals
and i don't care if you're a liberal
marxist anarchist libertarian everyone
is looking to the individual it seems
like
and not marx himself i mean internet
marxist of course
everyone's looking to individuals as the
locus of political agency
when systems are the locus of political
agency
and this kind of cashes out a little bit
in our spheres i'd say
with uh
debate lordism
masquerading as politics because
the whole process of debating back and
forth we're going to get a libertarian
on we're going to get a
i don't know an anarchist on they're
going to have a debate
this
assumes again that belief is the center
of the system and that if we just
convinced people that our arguments are
better then they would be on our side
and the system would change
but they're already caught up in the
system and every media implication that
is there they're probably talking on
twitch or probably talking on youtube
and so you're really
you're really putting a lot of weight
into human beliefs
not actually looking at
the
wider ecology or the wider environment
would be the technical term
there's never in history been a
revolution about belief i don't think
not even the reformation
yeah it it does seem like self-interest
is the baseline assumption and this is
common to debate lording and to politics
right like politics has a certain
conception of
self-interest that comes from economics
and because politicians want to come
across these days as good businessmen
they they have to follow this sort of
model of economics where you know the
marketplace will mediate between all of
our self-interests what is the market
the market's a [ __ ] system then right
and but they don't acknowledge that it's
we're rational actors in a marketplace
it's just like a neutral medium for us
to explore and if my self-interest is
gratified a little too much you know the
invisible hand or whatever they call it
now will will eventually correct that
and that's the kind of assumption in the
in debates like when we're
preaching to the choir it's all it's all
nice to assume that like neoliberal
economics and and survival of the
fittest darwinism is not the baseline of
our conversation but it seems like when
you go out into the public sphere
those things are
the
the
definitely one of the major basic
assumptions that you come up against
i've i've read a couple times to say you
know if you're talking to somebody on
the street i think even kerry wolf says
this if you're talking to someone on the
street it's better to be a humanist
because they're not going to understand
what the [ __ ] you're saying
oh yeah for sure if you're having dinner
with your family be a humanist just
that's good enough i mean like if you
start
if you start you know
talking to people like they're treating
a fork like an object and this and then
there's so like they're not really
nobody's gonna be responsible for that
the fork is a four-dimensional object
with a dark other side like see this
multi-species banquet we have who's
eating who here right
are we eating the food or
are we are we just are we just uh
compost and training i don't know it's
people aren't responsive to that kind of
thing it's it's nice though when you're
when you're preaching to the choir and
you have the safe space to work out your
ideas and let them grow and but that's
never the reality of these sorts of
things especially if you do want to
change
change the world in whatever small way
right you have to bring these ideas out
to other people
but you know what the practice this
element would actually be something like
accelerationism
because you'll notice
revolutions don't happen about belief
they happen
when there is like a power struggle
or hunger
right hunger causes revolutions if you
if you want to revolution marxists so
you know disrupt the supply chain make
everybody hungry because while you have
surplus laying around you got surplus
well
no revolution sorry
maybe if that surplus is really unevenly
distributed you can get people pissed
off enough to act which is to
communicate and irritate the system
but if everyone's you know relatively
happy if things change slow instead of
quickly
then
get personal interests your beliefs your
arguments about why your politics are
the better than everybody else is just
get them out of the picture because
that's a bad model
academic papers too arguing we need to
change the world in this way this second
order observation they do not change
things
you know if you want to change things
another thing we could bring up is we
haven't brought it up yet eric but it's
a systematic complexity
because the more complex a system is
the more difficult it is to change so in
a conversation between two people one
person can change the conversation a
whole lot because there's only two
inputs but in a conversation with 50
million people one communication event
on its own
does nothing which is why academic
papers are useless because it doesn't
matter how good your ideas are if
they're read by three people they may as
well
not exist
so own the communication and you can own
the system yeah and this podcast is an
example of that it is a very short chain
of communication which is
we could do this for a thousand years
and we would be nowhere near what
happens on twitter in a single [ __ ]
hour so
that's the scale of the problem
with with
from a social system's perspective
anyway i i i this came up in my trending
topics actually two things
um
do you know ben burgess he was on our
show like once or twice i think he was
actually on like four times but three of
the recordings didn't work oh yeah i saw
him speak in toronto not too long ago
so ben burgess went on joe rogan
and
i guess enough people to cause a stir
were upset with him for going on to joe
rogan because he's platforming and blah
blah blah so they're doing
they're doing an ideological
purity test on him
and the other thing that i oh i don't
i don't know really anything about this
guy but it keeps trending
on my twitter is hassan [ __ ]
because hassan [ __ ] bought an expensive
shirt do you know who this guy is
no
okay he's like
a twitch streamer
we get on a good episode we get like
maybe five or six thousand views
this
guy has like
30 000 viewers at any time of day oh
yeah hassan [ __ ] models shirts oh he's
he's an internet heartthrob
yeah so the the purity police came for
ben burgess and and hassan [ __ ] because
they're not socialist enough
so let me let me advance
from a system
andrio ocasio-cortez shirt i see
something about sex workers oh yeah so
he's he's he's modeling these uh
left leftist message shirts really he
just models sure let me see this
oh okay well
anyway
i watched a whole bunch of twitch people
while i was making my matrix video i i
don't know what to say i completely
don't get it but most of the main
streamers on twitch kind of play video
games and talk at the same time and also
watch youtube for for sometimes it's hot
100 000 people at the same time and no i
don't get it but
like this is twice the size of the city
i grew up in that watch someone play
video games
um
but
hassan [ __ ] didn't
game much um he was watching republican
you know thumb heads give speeches and
then
kind of talk about why what they were
saying was insane
and then he also brought up union stuff
and talked about like owner
owners exploiting workers in the music
industry or whatever
um and i did i did not watch ben burgess
on joe rogan but knowing his schtick it
was probably something about socialism
being a sound intellectual position or
whatever that is standard fair however
what twitter fed me
probably because of the people that i
follow so it's pegged me as someone who
is interested in this [ __ ] what twitter
fed me in the last two weeks or so was
that hassan [ __ ] is a fake
socialist because he went to coachella
and wears expensive clothes
and that ben burgess only cares about
selling books so he went on rogan to
boost his popularity or or whatever so
if the algorithm if the twitter
algorithm is correct these are the two
things that i saw
which the twitter algorithm sent me in
hopes that i would respond to these
things because i assume
that's what users like me on twitter
chose to respond to
and if that's what i i saw i assume
that's what
thousands of people were seeing and
reacted to
now being shown these [ __ ] fake
spectacle scandals scandals
you know for internet brain purity
police from what i gather
uh hassan [ __ ] is being attacked for
spending money i guess and and ben
burgess is being attacked for
platforming himself or platforming
joe rogan i couldn't really tell you and
i don't care i'm not their audience i'm
not a 17 year old gamer or or the debate
argument watcher but in any case if you
want
any leftist idea
a talking point you know uh
wealth redistribution the value of
organized labor
that
capitalism ex is exploitative
or whatever that communique is you
want it
said and the source
for the most part
does not matter you just i mean you
should just want the communique itself
to circulate
because the repetition of a communique
is itself
causal
it's a systemic irritant and reproducing
an irritant is itself
power as we might call it in different
terms so it's not political power not
yet but it's at least symbolic power and
if you think that good arguments
convince people
you have your academic head
already shoved up your own ass yeah so
if you're a leftist you should be
standing on
the [ __ ] sidelines which you probably
are clapping
for hassan
[ __ ] who has like 30 000 17 year olds
just listening to
leftist talking points
all day
and uh would they have a better
understanding of marxism if they were
all
listening to david harvey or someone
yeah duh of course but david harvey
doesn't offer any of the aesthetic
purchase to a 17 year old that this
twitch
gamer does
so i would like to say to to leftist
twitter
your your purity policing is lib [ __ ]
because communicates do not depend on
the source
purity politics is out
systems theory
mic drop there we go yeah virtue
signaling is something that's easily
co-opted by the very systems you're
trying to change
in order to simulate change
yeah and probably a massive reason that
you're unable to
make any headway in in somewhere like
the united states on even the most basic
popular issues is because of something
like fox news which is the most watched
news network in the united states
um
because even if a communique is wrong
it doesn't really matter it it matters
that it's said because what it's said is
what
makes
it matter and this is what trump is like
still after
after not being president is still one
of the most
powerful
republican politicians with his
endorsements and whatnot
simply because he as a as an image as a
message was communicated
so much constantly
through the news media yeah even the me
even the news media that is criticizing
him so from a systems theory perspective
there is no such thing as bad publicity
the more something it is is heard the
greater of an effect it will have if you
own the communication you own the system
yeah and this is why this is why speech
act theory is is
very insufficient i think because it
does look at individual speech acts and
why it was attacked by both
toulouse and gottari and their works and
derrida in limited inc
as well it was attacked is attacked from
various reasons but they're actually i
can connect it to something that you
were just saying and and to something
ben burgess said
which is was he he does get irritated
when people make that argument about
platforming you shouldn't even be
talking to these people you're
platforming them or you're you're
you're somehow validating their point of
view even though he's going on there and
arguing against them and his whole point
you know the title of his book give them
an argument
and the reason that this is relevant
here too is because it is you're right
nothing trump did no individual speech
act that he did and no collection of
them it was this sort of media
amplification right and it's the same
thing in the way when you construct an
argument
you're constructed in the form of
something that can be repeated at
infinitum so if we're in our workshops
as leftist coming up with good arguments
rather than getting out there and doing
performative speech acting and
virtue signaling and and you know
fly swatting or
whatever metaphor of whack-a-mole kind
of thing whack em as they come up
if we make these arguments
and we can get those arguments to catch
on and more people start making them
then you're really starting to
at least there could be a kind of
cascading effect to that if you come up
with a really sweet argument about
something and other people catch on to
it
then your individual speech act doesn't
matter at all because it's the argument
it's the form of what you're saying it's
the repeatability yeah this is where i'd
push back on you though it's not the
argument it's what you said after which
is just the repeatability so like
bernie's thing
bernie's saying tax the rich tax the
rich tax the rich tax the rich no
argument there
just like a
as a phrase that becomes almost its own
symbol and the more that circulates
the more powerful it becomes just by
repetition
so the republicans unders are like the
right wing completely understands this
they're not making them [ __ ]
arguments they're saying
think of the children think of the
children think of the children who's
coming for them we don't know
the gays are coming for them the
satanists are coming for them it doesn't
matter that you know you have to be
afraid for your children the disney's
the disney people they're going to
kidnap them
so i don't know this is this is my
argument against purity politics is you
want
the same thing said as many times and as
many ways as possible that aligns with
your views whether or not the person is
wearing a shirt that you think is too
expensive
yeah i mean it is the repeatability in a
way and the right is busy making memes
and making
making art in a certain way that is
infinitely repeatable in an online
context and it seems like the left is
losing that battle
but
you know from the left as well bernie
sanders also had his campaign against
big pharma well what the [ __ ] happened
on that one kovit came along we're
nobody's saying that anymore
that would be another interesting thing
to get back into mainstream culture
right like why are we giving big pharma
all of this
like
we're giving them credit and at the same
time protecting their intellectual
property right and
by that action we're creating them as
big pharma in a certain way as well
so if we just wave the patents and let
other people in but [ __ ] here we are
two three years later right they've like
it's too late now but holy [ __ ] if we
just thought like that from the
beginning then
maybe it would be a little different i
don't think we would have eliminated
covet because there's a lot of other
[ __ ] that covet relates to but then
again again again that's the another
difficulty with the system's perspective
is that everything is connected in a
certain sense no problem can be isolated
and treated
in a kind of
vacuum everything is linked to
everything else
in a very and it's no
it's no uh it it's no coincidence that a
lot of systems theorists are also very
interested in eastern philosophy and
also came into their own in the same
kind of
hippie drug culture of the 60s and 70s
that also made those sorts of claims but
in a more you know
kind of you know bhagavad bhagavad-gita
oceanic consciousness kind of way but
still kind of sets the sets the form up
for a new kind of argument to say well
yeah covet is connected to climate
change climate change is connected to
capitalism and neoliberalism
neoliberalism capitalism are connected
to
why you hate mondays like like gg likes
to say
i all those sorts of things are
interconnected and the problem with this
complexity
is that where do you start where do you
start your analysis where do you start
figuring [ __ ] out
if every
string you pluck
is also connected to 100 other strings
100 million other strings
yeah the one thing though that you need
to change a system especially
a complex system like if we if we just
say we want to overthrow capitalism
you need
so much force because capitalism is
maintained by
billions of interactions every single
day
like
i don't maybe billions per like hour i
don't i don't know i don't know the
numbers of this but you have to disrupt
i like either a weak pointers of the
system and it's not through belief even
though i'm saying you know you need to
control messaging to control
a society
even that won't be enough because as we
said
all systems are closed so even if you
control all the media
it does it's not necessarily going to
have an effect
yeah i i haven't brought this one up
actually
i don't i think i brought this up in our
original series we did on this sort of
stuff like
a year and a half two years ago
but you know the the law of requisite
variety the the idea that that only
complexity can absorb complexity
and so that's the reason say why
wealthy people don't need as much help
as people without money because when you
don't have money you lack the variety
you lack the complexity to absorb the
shocks that come to you from your
environment when the environment
perturbs you and you know that and
that's just a very
abstract way of saying you know if you
get sick if you lose your job if
something like that happens if you get
into an accident right
you don't have as much requisite variety
as a celebrity does so i mean i i get
into i get into it with my partner
sometimes because
we do follow sometimes you know like the
britney spears case and like other
famous celebrities who get into [ __ ] and
i'm like but these people don't need
help they have the requisite variety to
deal with these things it sucks just as
much for us as it does for them just as
much for them as it does for us yeah
okay we're all we are only human to fall
back on that but
they have much more requisite variety
they do not need [ __ ] help they can
fly to hospitals in russia and get crazy
cutting-edge treatments they can they
they can
put themselves into very nice
establishments that will help them get
off drugs or whatever they need to do
right
people can't do that we require a kind
of welfare state that has been
dismantled
because
when something happens to us we need
that extra variety and if we don't have
a welfare state then we have no
i don't know this could be even in like
thermodynamic terms we have we we are
closer to maximal entropy we do not have
the energy to do the work
to get us off drugs to help us absorb
that shock of sickness or death in the
family or whatever it might be yeah
or domestic abuse
true say true say like the big case de
jour is uh johnny depp
to be honest i have no idea what's
happening there but
despite the fact that he might feel the
same despair as anyone in that situation
would except with
requisite variety he probably has
several houses that he could escape
to
in that situation
a normal person in that situation of of
domestic
abuse
probably has no requisite variety and
there is no option
but to stay
so in in systems theoretical terms being
poor
is akin
to having
like an autoimmune disease
where irritations from the environment
can and not necessarily will but can
potentially have a much
greater capacity to disrupt
so you are much more susceptible to
changes in the environment than someone
without an autoimmune disease
which is
like if you if you have a healthy immune
system you're much more able to adapt to
irritations or
uh external interferences yeah and on a
much larger scale a good example too is
is again the way covid hit the economy
right because we had such a fine-tuned
economy and the supply lines were not
very flexible
the variety of the system had slowly
been you know
called
and cost benefit reduced or whatever
they do to it
and
you know
sent to other places so then when kovit
hit and stressed our supply lines they
immediately [ __ ] collapsed because
they had
no flexibility they did not again have
requisite variety to absorb this shock
again without
you know creating all of these horrible
consequences for people who then you
know and and as is the case you know all
the all the costs that things tend to
incur will fall on the people more than
they fall on the
wealthier sections who are actually
capable of [ __ ] doing something about
this but they don't because
again individualism neoliberalism
whatever
all right
so eric there's one big i asked for
questions on on our last public episode
and saw some of them
can you guess what uh the biggest
question was
um it usually has something to do with
uh
well how do we actually interact with
our environments
how do systems work what is
communication
yeah exactly i mean you've kind of said
it but it's all systems are closed how
can that be and how can that be when we
are talking as if these systems you know
uh wealth to
twitter trending topics to
an immune system how can these all be
closed if we're intermixing them all
um
they're closed and we're intermixing
them all in our conversation our
conversation is a second order system
which enables us to speak about all
these things in system theoretical
terms
right so
um
and this is kind of the the joy to me
the
the joy of systems theory is you use
exactly the same terms to describe an
economy an individual's personal
finances and
ability to survive based on those and an
immune system you can use the same words
to describe
each of them if you isolate the
variables enough and the variable in
each one is communication
now this sounds
very weird when we say things like
there's no money in politics
because everyone of course knows in
another sense of those terms there is
money in politics or you don't think in
language these are both claims of
systems theory
which is one kind of
posthumous model of explanation so this
sounds really weird don't worry
i know that it sounds weird
um
and it took it took a lot of work to
figure out which terms are technical
which are used for effect but
communications why don't we start with
that communication has a specific
meaning in systems theory
you can use it to describe a
conversation like eric and i are having
you're part of this communication system
just by
listening
to it
and you can't feedback directly so to
that it's closed it's a closed system
um
and you can use it to describe
conversation
like uh
non-specifically communication but when
we're talking about communication we're
talking about one thing having cause and
effect value and that's what a system is
it's where communication has value
yeah i mean
was i just saying earlier um
yes communication okay so we need to
describe what a
closed system
really is and how communication factors
into that and actually this is what i
wanted to say lumen brings up this
disclaimer even when he's explaining
this stuff is he'll say you know i'm
going to use some terms that i can only
really explain later because i'm talking
about this now so for now you just have
to accept the terms yes and then i'll
get to explaining them that's like you
know
systems are very complex so systems
theory right you just kind of got to
break into it and then work your way out
you there's no way to start at the
beginning because it's all recruit it's
all recursive it's all it's all
self uh self observations recursivity so
don't worry we know that it sounds
intuitively wrong to say that all
systems are closed and you're not alone
in thinking that and to say there's no
money in politics there's no language in
your psyche
and there's no human beings in society
we know that sounds weird to say and we
know why it sounds weird to say but eric
why don't you take it away
yeah so this this communication angle
comes from lumen
and his his teacher was named talcott
parsons and basically telcott parsons
equivalent was action right social
systems consist of actions
right and and lumen wasn't really happy
with this for various reasons i won't go
into
um but but he wasn't happy about
action being the basic unit of a system
they'd already kind of decided that the
human being isn't the isn't the unit of
the system um but so what is it its
actions okay well lumen wasn't really
happy with this
because
you know he'll say
like
we what we need to do is we need to
identify an operation
that meets certain conditions
and this operation has to be well this
is one of the conditions
it it's one single
operation it's not a bunch of different
operations so it's not you know
communication is one observation
payments in an economic system or
another operation or you know
power
and legitimacy is another operation in
the political system so each each system
has to be composed of only one kind of
operation it can't have a bunch of
different kinds of operations so instead
of action let's talk about communication
right it must always be the same and it
must be connectable
so communication breeds communication
breeds communication right you can think
of
this an analogy to
biological
systems right
the first
living cell
came along
and then there was life all life came
from there it happened once all life
came from that
life as a system its main operation is
is
what you say
reproduction i guess you could say it's
not communication per se it's
reproduction is their operation in a
sense right i mean it is communication
though it is communication
and you know i don't remember this very
well from high school biology but
um i don't actually have to but when
cells
like transcribe or re-transcribe dna
there is a communication
process there you don't
like you have the rna to dna thing that
is like communicating the transcription
process but the medium of that
communication which is communication
is a bunch of these like
floating molecules or whatever they are
nucleo nucleotides
i don't know where wherever they come
from they're the result of other
processes and the communication is made
of
basically
floating leftovers around that fit and
then they create you know the next
generation okay so let's call all that
stuff biochemical propositions and those
are all biochemical propositions
and in a social system the first social
system
well
we don't know where the first social
system came from we're just in a
situation and we see systems around us
some of them seem to be social systems
because they consist of communications
and so when you want to make this
rigorous let's say
only communications these these systems
consist of
self-propagating
self-generating ongoing sets of
communications if all communication
suddenly stopped the system would cease
to exist and as we say you know there
are billions of little communications
going on every day
in every system
and so i mean that communication would
stop is actually just crazy it never
does it happens all night 24 7.
um so
this is what lumen says here a social
system emerges when communication
develops from communication
so
we're speaking right now we're
communicating so there's a kind of
there's a kind of speech and response
kind of idea going on in in this right
and and the question of what was the
first communication lumen points out is
already a question within a
communicating system you can't really
answer that question from within
communication but
it's pretty clear that there are systems
and that communication
seems like the candidate for the single
basic operation that goes on in social
systems
so that's right and let me pick up for
you there
and the reason and communication in a
system is internal
the reason that we know
this is like the proof that systems are
closed
is that
communication between systems
has errors in it so we're not saying
that it i mean technically it doesn't
happen ever because they're closed but
when we have something called a
structural coupling that's how you get
something from one system to another if
you buy a politician
if you bribe them that would be a
structural coupling between you know
money as a system
and politics
insofar as that person can go and like
take your bribe and then vote for
whatever you paid them for
but because that can fail
because the guy doesn't have to take
your bribe that shows that those are two
closed systems so let me make this
let me just talk about what we are doing
right now we're having a conversation
if it were the case that i
am
a sender and eric is a receiver
then it doesn't make sense
that in a you know we have clear
equipment our equipment's working that
he could misinterpret what i'm saying
or we could say it another way that you
listener are listening to eric and i
communicate to each other you can hear
this because i've like converted it into
an audio file and uploaded it to the
internet
even if all that stuff is working you
can still
misinterpret me
if our communication was direct meaning
it was a cause that had an effect in
your brain there's no explanation as to
how it could be misinterpreted but
because they're closed in this case
there can be errors made just like in in
in dna transcription there can be errors
made which is how
evolution
occurs
but i can also misinterpret myself in a
sense
by
saying something that i didn't mean to
say like genuinely genuinely i can make
mistakes
that's because and the reason that i
know it's a mistake is because i didn't
say what i was thinking or i thought
after i said it
and i realized that i had made a mistake
that's because my psychic system
and language as a general social system
my psychic system is not social
the language system is
it's closed off one from another because
that mistake can be made
and this is gonna sound absurd i know
too
of course i think in language i'm laying
in my bed there's words going through my
head this is the link this is part of
language
and it's not it's closed
and the proof of that i guess as you as
you could uh
imagine is the thoughts in your head
do not contribute to language if you
come up with a new word in your head
and just leave it there
no one else is ever going to say that
word
right because it doesn't affect
language as the circulating social
system of all of english together now
it's very
very very difficult to change english
you could you could probably not do it
on your own it does happen
from time to time and the reason it's so
hard to change a language is because
there's so many people
speaking it
so it's in in terms of systems theory
it's extremely complex
complex things are very hard to change
they can change we get new words
invented
tik tok is is accelerating this process
a little bit
but your mind is cut off from the
language system once you speak something
then it has the possibility
the unlikely possibility but a
possibility nonetheless of actually
changing language as a social system but
that's why you would say something like
you don't think in language you think in
thought and language is distinct from
that but the fact that you speak in
english
i mean sorry the fact that you think in
english however shows that there is a
structural coupling between your psychic
system and that language social system
that everybody shares and everybody
contributes to
yeah i think
i think one way to make it sound less
weird um because in a way this is just
how it's talked about in systems theory
and so it doesn't have the benefit of
being very clear
lumen is not an easy person to
understand but you can think of it if
you've read you know
post-modern theory if you've read
darida or bars or foucault especially
especially you know death of the author
what is an author
basically anything
right that's right intentionality
does not determine the meaning of the
text right the author's intention is not
the meaning of the text which is just
another way of saying the psychic system
which is your thoughts does not
determine the meaning of language the
only thing that determines the meaning
of a communicative event
is really the next communicative event
and and so on and so forth until either
some kind of consensus is reached which
is rare or communication just breaks off
and goes in a different direction which
is more likely to happen especially in
the internet age but that's one way to
think about it right it's it's a very
sort of not simple but it's a very
common point
that postmodern theory is of the text
has been making for the past 80 years or
so is that intentionality
is just
you know it's one factor and it has to
be deduced from the text itself you
don't have any special access to the
brain of the person who wrote this text
and even while they were writing the
text they were interpreting themselves
in their own experience and having an
internal dialogue and blah blah blah
whatever came out of that in the form of
a text is a very
very incomplete and partial
representation of all of that
and then that takes on a life of its own
and becomes inserted into what is it a
book it becomes inserted into the the
art system the system of works of art
and literary texts or if it's a painting
you know this is the same sort of
podcast episode yeah exactly i could say
things that people interpret all kinds
of ways and i could say i didn't mean to
say that that's not what i meant
but in the end you know i don't really
get to dictate the meaning of the things
that i use because language is sort of
has to be that way for us to understand
each other
it may be it sounds weird but from a
sort of
analytic perspective it just makes sense
to treat systems this way is closed and
it's a lesson that deconstruction and a
lot of other post-structuralist thinking
gives us and it's just now being
translated
into
a theory that is constructivist instead
of deconstructionist but deconstruction
is always a gesture that has to be sort
of
made
that's like you know lumen writes you
know second order observation is
deconstruction deconstruction is second
order observation we have to begin by
deconstructing the term system
which all system means is
a difference and all all that is is the
difference between the system and the
environment
right it sounds very strange all of it
but it's actually some good stuff if
you've if you've been primed on post
structuralism it actually
would help to connect it to some of that
stuff and then the yeah another another
good
post-structuralist term would be the
trace
when you say a system is closed
then you're saying
it is the trace
of something that came from a different
system you don't know directly where
because it's now the resource of a new
kind of communication but the trace
marks an absence not a presence yeah
yeah the the trace structure is
something that again we do not have
direct access to we sort of
couple with it and try to
finagle it into different things that we
want it to be but in the end it's a
collective kind of thing that we don't
have control over derrida is trying to
think the difference between machine and
event
writing and
thinking
and making these kind same sorts of
distinctions i would say that lumen
really makes and
if you really want a quick way just to
start of well then okay if it's all this
communication then how are there even
different systems
well
communication needs a medium
and so the term here to use would be a
symbolically generalized medium of
communication
so the symbolically generalized medium
of communication that we
are currently operating in
is of course linguistics linguistic
language the symbolically generalized
medium that the legal system
operates in
is
what
power
validity validity is a legal term valid
and invalid right certain arguments are
invalid in the courtroom
um and also the economic system what's
that one's easy right money that's the
symbolically generalized medium of
communication in the economic system is
money we don't communicate with language
i don't pay you in words i have to pay
you in dollar bills
and so
those that's how you distinguish
different social systems from one
another if you're looking at specific
systems well we're we're sort of talking
about social systems in general at the
moment we don't get to the
functionally differentiated systems
until we get a little deeper into lumen
i think
yeah if you wanted to talk about
a system that was not closed like if
your mind was not closed say
then communication there would mean that
i am able to think your thoughts for you
the fact that i can't can never
is kind of proof of this closure and we
you and i eric are having this
conversation the listener is kind of
there but not really there they can't
they can't
uh communicate with feedback currently
they can feedback post hoc but if you
think about everything else that's going
into this conversation that are not in
the generalized system of exchange
because we're speaking in language right
but if you think about how
the listener is able to hear us you and
i are speaking into
microphones
right over the internet right now these
microphones are
turning
sound into digital files that are into
uh digital recordings that are gonna be
turned into one file that are gonna be
uploaded to the internet that when you
press play on your device on your phone
or whatever you're listening to this on
are causing compressions in the air
wherever the hell you are in your car or
in your house
um
and you can hear those compressions then
those thought process those that can
inspire a thought process that produces
either something comprehensible or
something incomprehensible to you so
we're not even just talking about one
thing happening these are all closed
systems where one system uses the
resources produced by another one for
itself
so i i'm causing air compressions in my
room which is how i make sound come out
of my mouth
the digital or the the microphone is the
kind of system that can turn
air into a digital file
but i can't my voice is not a digital
file right so although this entire
process
seems like direct you're just listening
to us talk
it's anything but direct
and i guess the proof of that is that
anything
anything could go wrong here my
microphone could be off
when i think it's on my internet could
fail while i'm uploading it i could say
something i don't mean and then it goes
out there and it gets clipped and then i
get i get called uh i don't know
whatever i get called
time's up while you're while you're
listening to this
your internet could cut out and you
wouldn't be able to hear it anymore any
single thing could happen in any one of
those systems which would prevent
communication
um
but because each of those systems is you
know relatively stable they deal with
millions of of interactions per day
it's pretty rare that
that most websites go down but when it
does go down that's when you notice it
that's when you really notice it
but you can see that any one of these
systems failing doesn't cause the other
systems to fail
if our if my internet cuts out right now
that wouldn't that wouldn't necessarily
work
um if something went wrong right now
eric and i would be able to keep talking
if something went on wrong on your end
and actually on your end this
conversation happened yesterday so
anyway this is kind of to connect it to
our last week's conversation that this
is like
there's anything but direct
communication occurring at this moment
while you are listening to us
um you are listening to an audio file
like either on spotify or that you
download it to your phone and that's
that's what you were listening to you're
not listening to us right now we're what
are you doing right now eric i mean like
tomorrow at
tomorrow and tomorrow afternoon what
will you be doing
uh i'll be uh dog
sitting okay so you're listening to this
while eric is dog-sitting
there you go
yeah
yeah i think
i like i always like to bring like the
biology examples into i'm not a
biologist but i pick up some things here
and there and and you know if you treat
say like i don't know a forest as as a
as a system right everything is
everything is is
eating and pooping right that's
basically what's going on there and and
so something is turning sunlight into
something else then something eats that
poops it out something else eats that
poop something else eats that whatever
that thing makes out of that poop right
and you so you've got this complex
system of all kinds of different things
trees and plants and animals and stuff
but see the the the new there's a kind
of nutritional medium i guess you'd say
it's a it's a a biochemical medium
anyway and it continuously sort of you
know just eating and [ __ ] eating and
[ __ ]
i think you just nailed it this is this
is the this is why they're closed every
system eats the [ __ ] of another system
yeah like if i walk through a forest it
does not recognize my presence unless
i'm stomping on things and making a big
[ __ ] fuss then it then it might
notice me and
but it only notices the parts of my
behavior that are
directly relevant to its medium of
communication it's not going to
recognize me it's not going to say oh
eric is in the forest now and
call the bears it's not going to do
anything like that because it doesn't
recognize me as a human it recognizes me
as
how the [ __ ] should i know it recognize
me as whatever is relevant to its
sort of functioning as a system
and so that's i mean you say the same
thing about the internet right the
internet doesn't recognize us we're just
user profiles or we're just whatever
right we're just clicks little data
inputs
over and over again yeah the we're just
a a cluster of data points at a data
broker somewhere waiting to be bought
and have ads targeted at us we're not
people to them
we are again potential i guess potential
dollar bills in the future but
yeah so
i mean that's a long-winded we we should
get back to this is systems theory but
we should get back to the the post-human
aspect of this this is a descriptive
model
now in most people's day-to-day life you
don't need to say
i listen to an audio file that was
uploaded by
pills and eric that was edited in this
program that they you know you don't
need to say all that you can just say i
listen to a podcast with pills and eric
that's that's fine that's normal
but if we're looking for the human
technically
where is it
where do you draw the
line is the human
my thoughts
is it eric's thoughts is it your
thoughts is it my body like you you
listener have zero interaction with my
body ever thank god
but
like where where do you put my humanity
do you put it in my intention
you you don't have a [ __ ] clue about
my intention
so
where does the human become useful in
this communication
and my answer my personal answer is it
doesn't it's not a useful model here it
doesn't add anything calling me a human
or calling me a not human
makes makes no difference
to me it doesn't add anything
so to bring this back to
social systems theory we started talking
about politics here
the human
ver
very rarely like the full human using
its mind using its body all of this
stuff together
is not very useful when you add it to
systems it's not very useful to explain
what the law does the legal system it's
not a very useful model for what
politics does if we have you know a
human that has self-interest at the
bottom of it it's not useful for what
the economy does
and what we realize
is with the post-humanism addition to
this systems theory we don't really need
the full
human
for anything it's a word that obscures
differences between systems not one that
adds to the accuracy of descriptions
yeah yeah and i would i would say in it
if we really want to talk about humans
in a
social systems theory perspective we
can't really
because
lumen has already decided and i think
with good reason that you know you take
an individual well what are you
interested in about this individual are
you interested like right yeah are you
interested in their bank account are you
interested in their vocabulary are you
interested in their health
they're all
they're first they're structurally
coupled with all sorts of different
systems
and second a human already consists of
you know you have your biological system
that's a different that's a type of
system you have your psychic system
that's a separate system right your your
body and your
mind
communicate with each other but not
with all the caveats we've just been
saying about communication they're
structurally coupled and they perturb
each other there's no shared
medium of communication there
your body communicates
with itself
and it you know
sometimes teases your mind a little bit
you know you feel that rumbling in your
stomach and you interpret that
perturbance as
oh hunger or you know you're sitting
inside
you have vitamin d deficiency god i feel
weird i need to go for a walk like you
your psychic system is constantly
interpreting your
biological system and then on the other
side of it your psychic system is is
coupled to the social system you're
you're constantly trying to interpret
communications that you're receiving
you're
they go in your ear
in a certain sense or they go in your
eyeball or how whatever you're looking
at
and
it creates a sort of
this this idea of perturbation or
irritation and then your psychic system
has to
interpret that according to its own
medium of communication and so
when you're trying to find the human
being it's it's just dispersed among
various different systems
so i mean yeah okay always in a common
sense way you can get by so that's a
human there yeah okay obviously but
we're not really we're doing it we're
doing a systems theoretical analysis
then that that's not going to cut it
because we need to look at again these
mediums of communication
and what closure means in that sense is
yes the com the system can only
communicate with itself in that medium
but also
you don't look at a system
like you don't go out and look
at say the economic system you you go to
a bank stand in front of the bank and
look at it are you looking at an
economic system no you're just looking
at a structure
you're looking at a structure that maybe
embodies
this
economic system right because
really what's important to look at when
you're looking at a closed system is its
organization the relations of relations
and those relations are realized in
structures
your
the organization of the body is realized
in the actual fleshy thing that you have
but that organization is not directly
observable you can only observe
let's say the
you can only observe the observations
right and that's
going into strange territory but we're
looking at second order
systems so second order means observers
observing
observers and i heard a really a really
maybe easy way to understand that is you
know the value of anything is not
related to its materials the material
thing in front of you you pick up
whatever's in front of your phone okay
how much is that phone worth is that
determined by the
material value of all the components of
the phone no it's not it is determined
by what other people think it's worth
right it's determined by what the what
the stock market says it's worth right
that's why stock markets are the the
financial market is speculative because
it's not valuing things based on their
value the value of the house for
instance can go up or down
it's not because the
bricks magically just get more and less
valuable during a day based on their
material components it's because
observers
are observing other observers who are
making observations right it's a second
order thing it's it's the economic
system is only valuing things based on
what
other people are valuing them at it
sounds strange but that would be first
order if it was the other way around
yeah even money like a five dollar bill
is not worth five dollars
actually
and five dollars might not be worth the
same five dollars might be worth
different today when like uh you know
inflation things like that like money is
not real value it's kind of it's social
value actually it's value to the system
and you don't determine that
in a similar way you don't communicate
with the internet if you could
then you could just be like sitting
alone and talking and the internet would
know what you're saying
which i guess it kind of does if there's
like an alexa in the room or if you're
talking into a microphone but no to
communicate with the internet you have
to like have an internet connection and
then be able to type something either on
your phone or your keyboard
that's the communication that it
realizes the internet doesn't recognize
you as a person it doesn't give a [ __ ]
you might be a bot it doesn't give a
[ __ ] communication will continue either
way a bot will [ __ ] stuff out it will
read it you can [ __ ] stuff out into your
keyboard or into your phone and it will
read that
but you as a
self-contained individual
you're not in the internet
it can't affect your mind though i
should say that
it actually makes me wonder something
you know how you know how they do
monetize things on youtube right based
on how many
like
likes and views you get right i wonder
if that's ever happened with a bot
in some kind of context i don't know if
twitter really does that but you know if
this twitter account's a bot account and
it has tons and tons of views i wonder
if it's ever gotten you know like job
offers or
offers to monetize
i think that sounds 100 like it's
much weirder things have happened so
that seems pretty like if you program
the bot to open its own bank account you
could just start getting paid suddenly
we'll have bots with bank accounts that
make loads of money and that's neither
here nor there i think a more another
intimate example
if i can go out onto
very dangerous territory here
and talk about
labor
and the marxist theory of labor right
well what is what is your labor worth
right you're trying to get a job you're
trying to sell your
your labor on the job market how much do
you think your labor is worth well in a
sense how much you think your labor is
worth is completely meaningless because
the market values your labor and it's
based on the total value the total
availability of labor and what needs to
be done
and so again your labor you
the value of what your body can do in a
day is is determined by second order
observation it's determined by
market observers observing other market
observers observing other market
observers and so on and so forth and the
fluctuations of those chains of
observations make values of things like
your labor or your car or whatever go up
and down
and the labor market being a very
important one for marxist theory
i don't know could we have a sort of
marxist systems theory
maybe not according to lumen but i think
um
i think that's a very sort of intimate
kind of thing because our labor is
valued on the market we all need to have
a job and
our labor is not valued according to
what we think about it or
how good your parents think you are at
doing something it's just it's a second
order thing right again second order
observers observing observers who are
observing other observers
constantly
and we haven't even talked about
self-observation yet which is a key
component of this but again like i said
it's that recursive thing right i'll get
to it later but just take us on take us
at our word for now and yeah lumen lumen
does bring up marks uh favorably
in different aspects and you can also
like credit marks with being
not
i mean at the beginning he's very
humanist and then like by capital he's
not very humanist he's much more
concerned with
uh value
and the way that value flows and and is
affected and controlled basically
like externally from humans humans
they do create value in terms of like
creating a commodity through industry
but the determinant value of
a thing is not up to any person a person
doesn't decide that once once it enters
you know uh the market
so
yeah i guess to to to circle to do full
circle here in summary this might sound
really weird there are no humans in
society but you could you could think
very easily
that we already do this most of the time
we we do this when we're not being
theoretical so
are there any humans
in a store
or are there just
um you know cashiers
managers
and shoppers
do you need a full human or is cashiers
managers and shoppers enough
if you go into
a psych ward everyone in the psych ward
are they a human well yeah colloquially
they are
but what matters in a psych ward is are
you a patient
are you an orderly
or are you a doctor everyone has a very
recognized
role and that's what matters to that
context so
what lumen is
what lumina is saying with society is uh
knocking over a sacred cow
and the sacred cow here is that
it's been never doubted pretty much by
by anyone in the political spectrum that
society is a group of humans
all he's doing is taking that logic of
the store where
there are like defined roles and that's
all that really matters while you're in
there or the psych ward that's all that
really matters
while you're in there um a patient
cannot give pills
to doc to a doctor but an orderly can
give pills to a patient it's like a
one-way communication in that sense
one
one form only that transfers only one
direction because of those roles
and kind of what lumen is saying is
think of society more like
one of those strictly defined
communication
contexts
rather than a collection of individuals
and if you buy this if you read a whole
bunch of it and like kind of internalize
it it doesn't really make sense to have
the human anymore because what does it
add
and you can say it adds something maybe
i'm missing something for sure no doubt
but when you look at the legal system
does the human add something or does it
matter
who's the judge who's the lawyer who's
the
plaintiff
and uh you know all the other [ __ ] that
i don't know about so think of society
like that it's a bunch of broken
contexts
that don't necessarily transfer one to
another you know
yeah the one i think
the way that
different kind of sociology would do it
is it would look at social roles like
you know
political system politician legal system
lawyer
economic system sorry i'm not saying
that that that's definitely what it
sounded like but why don't you correct
me no no i mean i was just trying to
give a contrast there because it would
i mean if we did look at systems as
consisting solely of human beings at
least social systems then it would be
really hard to make distinctions
between
you know political legal social
education art system all the different
functional systems in a society would be
very hard to make those distinctions the
only other way you could do it would be
to look at roles
social roles and this this is kind of
marx's approach to what sorts of roles
become available under capitalism the
capitalist the laborer
the petty bourgeois all those sorts of
roles right so so marx's marx is
obviously pioneering this new approach
and it's something that that systems
theory i think is departing from quite
radically in a certain way
but doesn't need to throw the baby out
with the bathwater because
you know communications are then we
found a way to distinguish these systems
based on their
like i said before it as a reminder the
symbolically generalized medium
of communication so all these systems
operate via communication they just have
different mediums again to remind you
this is a language one that you're
hearing
in the case in case you think we're made
of money we are not i wish that were the
case but you know we can dream and then
i guess um you can help us be made of
money just
join the patreon
and i do want to correct myself before i
forget because if it sounds like i can
hear the misinterpretation happening
um tomorrow
if it sounds like i'm saying that
there's just roles in context that's not
really what systems theory is saying i
was using that as an analogy but what
makes each of those people
their role
is the actions that they are able to do
if they if they are not doing anything
the system does not recognize them once
you are done your credit card payment
like you tap your card or whatever
the system doesn't know you exist like
in in its world
in its reality which is a term that
lumen actually uses that there are
different realities that never meet up
together in the reality
of the credit system after you tap your
card
you disappear
from reality you might reappear again
once you tap again but as in so far as
the system is concerned you're not a
person it doesn't give a [ __ ] someone
might steal your card and use it it
doesn't care
yeah that's all
is the event yes exactly so it's an
event
based
uh methodology
yep that's just a communicative event
that links up to other communicative
events that respond to it there's no
then you the human being leaves is left
behind you don't
follow your money through your wire
transfer and pop out on the other side
only your money does
right well
this is another good example when you go
to an atm and deposit money
that money doesn't go anywhere it's
still sitting right in the atm it's
there
but like
i'm gonna reuse your example because i
think it's good i'm gonna re-shit out
your example
that you [ __ ] your money into
the atm
the money itself
shits its value into digital format it
goes through whatever internet and is
deposited into your bank account as a
number the money's still there the money
never moved
but this value exchange has taken place
in three different closed systems you
as a person who's holding the money the
atm as a box that could that is
connected to the internet and then
i don't know how banking works how bank
accounts work but whatever happens
whatever happens over there it happened
as a closed system and your money your
[ __ ] is still in the atm
it's a little bit a little bit of the
danger of trying to describe
in detail what goes on is you gotta just
know everything about everything but i
think
it gets the point across and i think
to return to
maybe to post humanism on this one too
it's um
you think where does the ethics come
from is there no ethics to this is it
kind of a morally dangerous point of
view to take up and i would say in a way
no because
lumen is
maybe more what
is described as anti-humanist but more
importantly he's not trying to be
normative he's not trying to
make value judgments he's not trying to
you know make moral pronouncements on
these things he's just trying to
describe it
and he's not trying to make moral claims
so
what post-humanism seems to do
is
it actually puts a higher premium on on
arguments that are
value-based and value-driven i think
there's a certain moral imperative
to regard
you know
other beings
with a non-hierarchical
radically sort of
different value system right like
you know what's your
what is your how much money is your
grandma worth or something like that we
can't translate the value of a human
into the value of money we can't
translate the value of an animal into
the value of of whatever hamburgers you
can't do that because everything
it's a kind of pluralistic framework
so
the value the the more the morality the
ethics the praxis
that goes into the praxis i should say
comes from a kind of
leveling of hierarchical relationships
and i think social systems theory does
this too in a certain way it levels the
hierarchical relationships
in the sense i guess maybe just limited
to that you know it doesn't put the
humans at the center of every single
social system in fact it evacuates
humans completely and dissolves them
into biological and psychic systems
instead yeah i'm trying to think of any
place where you would have a hierarchy
and it's like
a an imminent world it doesn't have
hierarchies there are stronger and
weaker systems
right yeah there would be systems
valuing themselves in various ways but
that valuation might not
you know it might not carry on to other
systems it might not it might just be a
local contingent valuation that changes
very quickly
yeah
so strong systems are basically just
very complex ones weak systems
are ones that don't have a lot of moving
parts like this conversation it's a weak
system we can just turn this off with
one button at any time and there would
be no flexibility or variety in
but we could pick it up again next time
and it may be picked up in the chats
in the discord on the internet it may be
picked up in various ways and live on
through that but
it would be a kind of yeah it would be
more at that anyway and uh yeah that's
it that's interesting so if they if they
give feedback to us
they're not actually giving feedback to
us
right because we're having this
conversation they're they have no
feedback right now but
once they feed back then we can read it
but we are no longer ourselves as we are
at this moment
yeah
yeah we could we could listen to our own
podcast and we'd be communicating to
ourselves actually
in a certain sense yeah and i think if
we go back and you know if you read the
feedback later you're
then you're sort of again
structurally coupling to a communicative
system and you sort of have to interpret
it right
bad feedback might make me feel bad good
feedback might make me feel good good
feedback might me give me new ideas i
try out next time or new topics i didn't
think of approaching next time and then
i then again i
i have to then
do what structurally couple again with
the communication system put those ideas
out there in the form of language
which is then then it leaves me then my
intentions don't carry along with the
words i use
and so maybe that's a way to there's
another word we haven't used yet which
is selection so you're going to have to
select
which which which of those communiques
are relevant which ones
you want to use to change your future
behavior and so on
yeah yeah and what about those
communications i might find relevant i
might see
there might be a really great comment
and i pass it over because i don't think
it's relevant that would be my mistake
but in the end that's just sort of how
it works that would be a kind of
miscommunication
or even if you can even describe it in
those terms it would just i would just
interpret in a certain way
and i would
select it for removal from my care
yeah but there also might be like a
really
bad
comment that you interpret
as something much more profound that it
was intended and that would still be a
correct communication even if you
misinterpreted it so
yeah even if i would have an effect on
the podcast
and then if i gave that interpretation
back to the commenter who just did it
off the cuff they might be very
surprised by how deeply i read into it i
was stoned when i wrote that yeah it
would be completely valid on my part to
read into it in that way and it would be
valid for you to be surprised that your
your off-the-cuff communication had such
an impact on me so
always always go for it i guess
if you're not first
you're last
so next week uh what you have to look
forward to because we already planned
for it and then this took up all the
time
but what you have to look forward to is
uh
do i want to say shitty or just bad
there's also really bad posthumanism
that says
some
very unconvincing things and leads to
very poor models really what we're
arguing for here is that this is a
better model
of a lot of things and
most things it's not very useful in your
day-to-day life but it's useful if you
want to figure out why something doesn't
work
like
i.e
revolution why doesn't it work well not
enough people are hungry
so
why don't we call it there you can look
forward to some uh some some bashing
next week at least from me i think
eric's a little bit more sympathetic
when it comes to
the authors about whom we'll be talking
but uh for now
good one dude
yeah i think so yeah i think well we'll
get i i think there there is a limit to
my enjoyment of post-humanism so maybe
it will
come up a little bit next week i like
what it's about but sometimes i just
don't like the way it
communicates inside
i want to i want to learn about gaia
so
hey oh the gaia hypothesis yeah i want
to learn about the guy hypothesis i
don't know anything about that and it
sounds
like it could be very misinterpreted but
it also sounds quite cool so
lovelin margulis love james lovelock
yeah we'll get into it
alright goodbye listeners this is a the
end of our communication
for today
communication
[Music]
you